m
le cross de l'antenne ouest unss s'est
déroulée ce mercredi 4 novembre à
l'étang saint paul
ce sont plus de 1500 élèves qui ont
participé aux différentes courses
l'antenne l'ouest de l'urss s'engage
dans une démarche d'intégration de tous
lors de ces grandes manifestations
cette épreuve a donc également été
ouverte aux élèves en situation de
handicap
c'est la manifestation de l'année avant
cette manifestation sur la gale nous
rassemblons ça fait plus de 3 500
rennais et delà de la course
le procès
est une hausse de compétition
qualificative pour le championnat
d'académie voir le championnat de france
nous avons ajouté à cette journée une
marche fonker la marche on car elle
constitue simplement à intégrer des
élèves qui n'ont pas la possibilité de
faire de la compétition mais qui
souhaiteraient quand même être à l'urss
et notamment des élèves qui sont en
situation de surpoids des élèves qui ont
un handicap mental léger ou voir moteur
et à ce moment là on programme un
parcours particulier pour eux ce qui ne
les empêche pas d'intégrer la course
c'est à dire qu'on va pas les
stigmatiser une sont pas mis d'accord
ils sont dans une courbe ce n'est avec
un parcours bien plus court l approche
du téléthon un appel aux dons a été
effectué auprès de tous les participants
aucune obligation juste une
sensibilisation à la générosité de
chacun
l'occasion pour les jeunes d'en savoir
un peu plus sur cette opération que dans
le cadre de l'organisation du cross de
district
cette année on a voulu s'associer à
l'opération téléthon
certains établissements ramène des
enveloppes avec un petit peu d'argent
pour ceux qui ont bien voulu donner et
parallèlement pendant la manifestation
le stand vend un certain nombre de
produits qui rapportera de l'argent
aussi pour l'opération téléthon c'est
une occasion d'appliquer des jeunes sur
la cause défendue par les femmes à
savoir les malades les maladies
neuromusculaires
donc c'est une manière aussi de les
sensibiliser
à la situation de ces malades à la
réunion il ya plus de 800 personnes sont
concernées par la maladie
et puis en même temps ça se fait dans un
esprit festif et l'objectif ce type
collecter des fonds une journée festive
et conviviale qui a permis aux 1500
participants de s'exprimer sur le plan
sportif mais aussi d'en ressortir avec
une vision citoyenne de ce que peut être
le sport ya le respect aussi ses chances
ont participé